[Musique]
champ de bataille cimetière
fortification musée la France possède un
patrimoine militaire unique sans
équivalent dans le monde trace de
l'histoire ces lieux intéresse les
visiteurs à la fois pour le cadre
fabuleux qu'ils peuvent offrir mais
aussi et surtout pour les histoires
qu'il raconte
longtemps méconnu ces lieux de mémoire
suscite aujourd'hui l'intérêt du grand
public
quel est le rôle du ministère des armées
dans le domaine comment arrive-t-il à
attirer et impliquer les jeunes
générations et comment faire vivre ce
devoir de mémoire pour ce nouveau numéro
du journal de la défense nous vous
invitons à découvrir 5 plus
emblématiques du patrimoine militaire
vestiges des conflits passés
[Musique]
deuxième acteur culturel de l'État après
le ministère de la Culture le ministère
des armées possède un vaste patrimoine
mémoriel son entretien et sa
valorisation sont placés sous la
responsabilité de la direction des
patrimoines de la mémoire et des
archives cette organisme a pour objectif
de permettre au plus grand nombre de
mieux comprendre les enjeux passés
présents et à venir du monde
contemporain le tourisme de mémoire est
un tourisme particulièrement important
dans notre pays qui prend de l'ampleur
notre rôle est double d'abord entretenir
valoriser restaurer les lieux de mémoire
par exemple les 275 nécropoles les 2200
carré militaire
[Musique]
nous avons aussi toute cette histoire du
monde de combattant au travers de CO2 de
mémoire ils sont bien sûr de notre
responsabilité c'est nous qui les
entretenons c'est nous qui les resterons
[Musique]
le ministère soutient cette initiative
qui permettrait peut-être en 2021
d'inscrire le front de l'ouest de la
Première Guerre mondiale au patrimoine
de l'Unesco
par ailleurs le ministère des armées
soutient les initiatives locales des
différents acteurs que peuvent être les
collectivités territoriales ou bien les
associations ou même d'ailleurs des
partenaires étrangers dans le tourisme
de mémoire
[Musique]
la première étape de notre voyage dans
l'histoire débute dans l'Est de la
France à Gravelotte à quelques
kilomètres de Metz
c'est ici qu'est né le tourisme de
mémoire au lendemain d'un des premiers
conflits contemporains la guerre
franco-allemande de 1870
une guerre souvent oubliée qui est
connue pourtant des combats d'une rare
violence
[Musique]
Gravelotte fait partie des batailles
autour de Metz qui sont déroulées entre
le 14 et 18 août 1870 et ça va être un
moment véritablement important dans
l'histoire de cette guerre est un des
endroits on aura le plus de morts et de
disparu entre 65000 et 70 000 temps du
côté français que du côté allemand et
c'est surtout un endroit dans lequel on
va se battre pour pouvoir garder ses
territoires français le territoire de la
Moselle notamment
ils ont fait des croquis pour français
mais également du côté allemand on va se
retrouver avec une volonté bien de
rendre hommage à ses victimes c'est
héros même si du côté français on a pu
perdre on considère quand même que ce
sont des des héros et on va petit à
petit et bien essayer d'imaginer quelque
chose pour le rendre hommage c'est à
partir de là que vont naître les
cimetières militaires font naître
également les nécropoles
[Musique]
la halle du souvenir et le seul monument
d'envergure qui a été construit par les
Allemands au même entre les deux nations
pour rendre hommage à l'armée allemande
d'un côté et à l'armée française de
l'autre en fait dès la fin des combats
de 70
on décide et bien de d'essayer de réunir
les victimes de cette guerre en un seul
et même lieu et en 1918 donc au moment
où l'armistice est déclarée assez
rapidement on va avoir une levée des
Français qui vivaient sur ces
territoires sur Metz et les environs qui
vont s'en prendre à l'ensemble des
monuments qui ont été érigés pendant
l'annexion
vous allez avoir la du souvenir qui va
être criblé de balle en partie à partir
de 18 des statues à l'intérieur les
bustes les médaillons en bronze vont
être renversés vont être fondus vont
être détruits on va avoir un regain
d'intérêt de la France pour cette halle
du souvenir après 1918 qui va être en
fait dans le dans l'idée de la
francisation de cette zone anciennement
annexée avec également et bien toute une
série de cérémonies qui vont être
réalisées pour autant on gardera en
parallèle l'Estelle allemande et en
gardera aussi des tombes qui ont été
érigés par les familles des victimes
allemandes dans ce même cimetière
encore aujourd'hui des touristes
seulement seront à Gravelotte pour
rendre hommage à la mémoire de leurs
anciens combattants
nous avons beaucoup de touristes
allemands qui viennent ils apprécient
effectivement de comprendre cette part
d'histoire et la mise en oeuvre et la
mise en valeur si vous voulez de cette
partie de l'histoire franco-allemande et
est très appréciée aux parents parce que
la mémoire est quelque chose qui doit se
travailler au quotidien c'est quelque
chose effectivement qui doit se
transmettre donc on travaille énormément
et on essaie de travailler de plus en
plus avec les écoles on essaie de
travailler de plus en plus avec les
collèges pour que cette transmission se
fasse et pour que cette histoire de la
Moselle et de la Lorraine et on va dire
de l'Est de la France soit plus connu
parce qu'elle le méritait
le musée a ouvert ses portes en 2014
avec l'objectif de continuer de parler
de ce conflit de cette guerre qui est
considérée comme étant la mère des deux
autres guerres mondiales et puis faire
en sorte que l'on n'oublie pas du tout
ce qui s'est passé pour montrer
également et bien à quel point cette
guerre de 70 a eu des échos non
seulement au niveau local au niveau
national au niveau européen il va faire
se poser aussi la question tout
simplement d'une construction européenne
avant l'heure
transmettre de manière vivante une
histoire et un patrimoine commun à deux
pays c'est également l'objectif d'un
autre lieu emblématique des armées le
Hartman villers-copf les poilus
appelaient la montagne mangeuse d'hommes
située dans le massif des Vosges ce lieu
a été le théâtre d'affrontement féroce
française également si son violemment
battus pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale de là-haut on a une vue à 180
degrés sur la plaine d'Alsace on y voit
la frontière suisse mais aussi vers la
ville de Colmar et ce qui était
intéressant pour les Français c'est
aussi la ligne de chemin de fer Mulhouse
Colmar Fribourg ou Mulhouse Colmar
Strasbourg parce que du côté allemand
tout venait par le chemin de fer et donc
c'était important de bombarder cette
ligne de chemin de fer pour ce faire il
fallait placer des officiers pour régler
le tir d'artillerie parce que ils ont
envoyé les obus de à peu près 7 8 km et
pour toucher une ligne de chemin de fer
c'était pas évident voilà c'est rocher
était bien
donc l'enjeu c'était le rocher panorama
porte d'entrée sur le hartmanwiller COPS
l'Historial franco-allemand retrace
l'histoire de la Grande Guerre en Alsace
il sert de trait d'union entre la
nécropole qui abrite 6 au suaire et les
tombes de plus de 1200 soldats
le monument national composé d'un hôtel
de la patrie et d'une crypte véritable
cathédrale souterraine
et le champ de bataille l'un des mieux
conservés de la Première Guerre mondiale
le sommet avec sa crête sometal a changé
en 1915 8 fois de côté huit fois une
fois c'était allemand une fois c'était
français
évidemment des combats très durs avec
des pertes énormes d'une d'un côté
groupe de l'autre et le dernier combat
le premier jour a été gagné par les
Français avec l'aide de l'ensemble du
régiment du 15-2 les fameux Diable Rouge
mais malheureusement ils ont été tournés
par le huitième guerre allemand et puis
c'était la défaite mais une défaite
sanglante
[Musique]
enfin ils ont conclu à partir de
mi-janvier 1916 que là-haut il fallait
s'arrêter ça coûtait beaucoup trop de
vie humaine ils se sont enterrés
définitivement les Allemands côtés
nord-est et les Français côté sud-ouest
il s'est resté ainsi jusqu'en fin de
guerre un peu plus de 100 ans après les
nouvelles recrues du 152e régiment
d'infanterie sont mobilisés pour
participer au maintien du champ de
bataille et de ses tranchées l'occasion
pour elle de découvrir ce lieu
emblématique de l'histoire de leur
régiment et d'apporter leur pierre à la
préservation de son patrimoine pour bien
savoir où l'on va il faut savoir d'où
l'on vient et nos jeunes ne connaissent
pas forcément l'histoire du régiment en
franchissant ses portes et c'est pour
cela que on les invite à feuilleter
l'album de famille en salle d'honneur au
quartier et puis beaucoup plus vieux
sympathique c'est de visiter une
situation
et c'est vrai qu'en arrivant ici c'est
très impressionnant on se rend compte de
de tous ces tous ces vestiges qui qu'il
y a qui sont encore assez bien préservés
et c'est vrai qu'on sent tout petit
c'est impressionnant de s'imaginer les
soldats qui étaient ici à l'époque donc
on combattu et c'est une certaine fierté
aussi on est un peu les descendants de
ses anciens du casque de qui était là
nous on participe à la restauration donc
ça permet déjà d'entretenir la mémoire
du lieu ce qui est très important et
puis ça permet aussi au marcheur de
pouvoir emprunter les sentiers en toute
sécurité et pouvoir marcher dans les pas
des anciens combattants qui étaient là
c'est un devoir de mémoire aujourd'hui
on a tendance à oublier vite avec les
nouvelles technologies donc à travers
les anciens qui sont là ils nous
racontent un peu et ça peut être
véhicule et le message du passé les
soldats ici avaient entre 20 et 30 ans à
17 ans on pouvait se rentrer à l'armée
comment expliquer à des jeunes tout ça
c'est souvent difficile donc le devoir
de mémoire c'est une explication essayez
de transmettre ma mémoire à la jeune
génération je trouve que c'est important
et tant que je pourrais je le ferai déjà
on a une indication enjeu majeure pour
le ministère des armées ce tourisme de
mémoire a aussi un rôle civique et
pédagogique pour la transmission du
patrimoine mémorial notamment vers les
jeunes générations du tourisme de
mémoire pour sensibiliser les jeunes
pour les utiliser comme passeurs et pour
le inculquer les valeurs qui sont les
valeurs combattantes l'engagement
l'héroïsme le dévouement pour autrui et
puis les valeurs de la Résistance pour
faire court liberté égalité fraternité
tout ce qui est particulier rééducation
nous soutenons sur le plan pédagogique
en partenariat avec l'Éducation
nationale et le ministère de
l'Agriculture un certain nombre de
lycées plus de 600 font des propositions
qui consistent à faire travailler les
jeunes sur une thématique particulière
en lien avec la mémoire d'ailleurs c'est
la concerne effectivement un projet en
classe mais souvent une visite sur un
site Memorial la partie du moment où
nous trouvons que ces projets sont
intéressants nous les subventionnons en
gros nous subventionnons environ 900
projets chaque année et dans le cadre du
service national universel les jeunes
participeront à des modules obligatoires
d'une journée dont un spécifiquement
consacré au devoir de mémoire il s'agira
de montrer aux jeunes pourquoi il est
toujours
utile comme autrefois avec nos anciens
de s'engager pour la patrie quelle est
la véritable signification de la
participation à une commémoration
histoire ne s'apprend pas que dans les
livres elle devient plus vivante sur les
lieux qui l'ont faites comme ici au
mémorial du Mont Faron à Toulon où nous
retrouvons une classe de CM2 dans cet
écrin de verdure est retracez une page
essentielle de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale le débarquement de Provence du
15 août 1944 totalement rénové en 2017
le mémorial du Mont Faron propose un
voyage dans l'histoire à travers des
guides de l'Office national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre le NAC
VG
de mémorial explique tout le
débarquement de Provence donc ce qu'on
appelle l'opération Dragoon et toute la
campagne de libération de la Provence
qui s'étale entre le 15 août 1944 et le
28 août 1944
[Musique]
ce qui me plaît le plus dans mon travail
c'est transmettre c'est transmettre
les valeurs effectivement véhiculé par
le ministère des armées c'est
transmettre ses valeurs républicaines et
bien entendu c'est faire aussi
transmettre ma passion de l'histoire
pour les jeunes générations aujourd'hui
on va
étudier un événement de la seconde
guerre
mondiale débarquement de Provence
effectivement est-ce que vous connaissez
des grands personnages à la Seconde
Guerre mondiale vas-y
voilà Dolf Hitler alors parmi les alliés
qui est-ce qu'il y avait
Churchill effectivement c'est le premier
ministre de la Grande-Bretagne d'accord
et le dernier qui est américain
Roosevelt voilà c'est jeune générations
sont très intéressés par mémorial parce
que la scénographie est en très
contemporaine c'est une génération qui a
l'habitude des vidéos de l'audio et qui
se reconnaît dans toutes ces
scénographies
[Musique]
c'était celui qui tirait les canons sur
un navigateur l'après-midi du 16 août
les troupes françaises entrent dans
l'action les premiers contingents de
l'armée du général de Lattre de Tassigny
full les plages de Cavalaire et de La
Croix-Valmer alors qu'il était prévu de
libérer Toulon à j+20 et Marseille agit
plus 40 le plan s'accélère
on passe d'un savoir qui est très
théorique en classe et une mémoire un
peu auditive à savoir qui est beaucoup
plus concret beaucoup plus réel on fait
appel à leur mémoire visuelle donc il se
projette il voit les choses et il passe
une théorie à une réalité concrète
l'histoire qui est l'histoire de la
France donc en ça voilà c'est c'est pour
eux une capitalisation du savoir à
l'école on apprend ce qui s'est passé
comment ça s'est passé et puis après là
on comprend les tenues comment c'était
comment à peu près ils ont attaqué on
voit des on apprend des petites choses
sur la géographie on apprend des choses
en plus
ah ben j'ai trouvé les élèves très
captivés c'est vrai que ça leur parle je
pense que ça sollicite aussi tout leur
sens donc je sais que j'ai des élèves
qui sont déjà passionnés d'histoire et
là je crois que ça prenait de sens aussi
particulièrement parce que c'est c'est
local donc c'est dans leur région mais
c'est vrai que ça les touches
personnellement
le Mont Faron avec 8 autres sites
appartient à ce qu'on appelle les hauts
lieux de la mémoire nationale site de
recueillement de commémoration et de
transmission ces mémoriaux incarnent le
souvenir de ceux qui ont combattu pour
la France notre prochaine étape nous
amène justement à la découverte d'un de
ces lieux le Mémorial national de la
prison de Montluc
au lieu de la mémoire nationale depuis
2010 mon Luc est aussi la seule prison
contemporaine visitable c'est un lieu
exceptionnel qui a traversé une grande
partie du 20e siècle puisque la prison a
été construite en tant que prison
militaire en 1921 et qu'elle a fermé
donc en février 2009 en tant que maison
d'arrêt pour femme de la ville de Lyon
si tu as été obligé particulièrement
pour son histoire de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale d'abord utilisé par la
Troisième République comme prison
militaire on a ensuite une utilisation
sous le régime de Vichy on a notamment
des résistants qui sont déjà emprisonnés
ici à l'époque puis en 1943 une
réquisition par les autorités militaires
allemandes avec un lieu qui va devenir
principalement un espace de transit pour
des personnes juives résistantes
otages majoritairement déportés après
leur passage dans ses murs et également
un certain nombre de massacres de
prisonniers sur les derniers mois avant
une libération par la Résistance sous
l'occupation allemande 10000 personnes
transitent entre ces murs au printemps
44 la prison est surpeuplée 1300
internets pour une capacité de 127
places mon Luc constitue alors la
première phase du processus de
déshumanisation voulue par les nazis une
antichambre vers la déportation et les
exécutions depuis l'ouverture du
Mémorial un gros travail qui a été fait
pour permettre d'identifier
celui la Gestapo lieu d'internement et
notamment de recréer le lien aussi dans
l'esprit des Lyonnais avec l'histoire de
Klaus Barbie puisque le procès de
l'ancien chef de la Gestapo a lieu en
1987 a laissé des traces dans beaucoup
de mémoire chez les Lyonnais
[Musique]
il s'agit à la fois donc d'entretenir la
mémoire du lieu mais d'être aussi un
site d'histoire on accueille de nombreux
visiteurs différents notamment une
grosse partie de public scolaire on a
mis en place des ateliers à partir de
documents d'archives qui permettent aux
élèves de retracer l'histoire d'Internet
de la prison de Montluc on a aussi pour
mission d'entretenir la mémoire des
internés qui sont passés ici on fait
encore intervenir certains survivants
parmi eux Jean Monin à l'appel du 18
juin du général de Gaulle il entre dans
la Résistance avec son père il dissimule
des armes et alerte ses camarades de
l'arrivée des SS le 24 janvier 1944 il
est arrêté par les Allemands et
incarcéré à Montluc sous une fausse
identité il y restera un mois avant
d'être transféré au camp de Mathausen en
Autriche Jean n'a que 16 ans et demi
j'ai découvert
mes compagnons des fortunes au nombre de
7,7 se faisait le 8e les questions
commencent tout viens-tu qui es-tu
pourquoi tu es arrêté c'est toutes ces
questions qui sont désagréables et aussi
la première chose retourne tes poches
savoir s'il y a du tabac
des cigarettes avec du papier journal
Jean a conservé un vif souvenirs de ces
conditions de détention pasteur de
mémoire il a posé son témoignage sur le
papier
pour moi pas il aperçu il fallait
absolument
une grande préoccupation c'était d'être
toujours sous mégarde et quand
j'entendais au premier étage les gares
qui arrivaient comme ça fait ça
résonance et quand ils arrivaient des
fois tiens l'important peu importe qui
est d'ici 10 Jean-Moulin tu restes
historique il y a tout un schéma qui se
crée vous savez quand vous avez vu la
mort en face vous étiez à la vie
[Rires]
couché sur une paillasse à même le sol
tête bêche la promiscuité les besoins
dans la tinette ça aussi terrible
quand même quelque chose c'est vraiment
la baisse
la tension permanente tirée dans la
cellule dans un transfert de méfiance
collectives qu'elle est toujours
possible il y a un mouton
dans une cellule un gars qui là
avec les cellules à côté du morse qui
connaissait et communiquer en tapant
encore
et puis contrôler les tuyaux
[Musique]
quand vous aviez dans les cellules les
gars qui étaient appelés il était où
avec les bagages ou sans bagages sans
bagages c'était la fusillée avec bagage
qui était parti en vacances
mon pantalon
c'est tout ce que j'avais
l'espoir l'espoir toujours l'espoir
jamais baisser les bras
Jean menace était un peu de temps après
notre rencontre il avait 92 ans
[Musique]
pour clore ce tour d'horizon du tourisme
de mémoire direction le Vercors c'est
ici que se trouve la plus petite
nécropole nationale du territoire situé
à 1600 mètres d'altitude ce cimetière
est aussi le plus difficile d'accès pour
y parvenir il faut gravir un sentir
rocailleux et pendu pendant une heure et
demie sportif curieux amoureux
d'histoire et de nature ils sont 50000
randonneurs à l'arpenter chaque année
ont été érigés là-haut en hommage aux
actes de bravoure des résistants à l'été
44 le site est entré sous le giron de
l'État en 2018 il se trouve qu'à mince
qui est une ville à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de chichilian était
constituée une compagnie civile d'une
vingtaine de jeunes donc le 19 juillet
ils vont prendre position ici au pas de
l'aiguille sur cette falaise qui était
censée être infranchissable qui était
une barrière de cette forteresse
naturelle qui est le Vercors où il
fallait du coup protéger les différents
pas les différents accès qui étaient
possibles au sein de cette falaise des
troupes de montagne de l'armée allemande
spécifiquement entraînée vont assaillir
le massif par ces fameuses crêtes donc
l'ennemi attendu par le petit sentier
qu'on emprunte pour arriver jusqu'ici
prend un revers les maquiseurs qui vont
d'abord se replier dans la grande grotte
mais sachant qu'ils vont être à
découvert à partir du moment où les
Allemands vont descendre sur le vallon
vont se réfugier dans cette petite
grotte
ils vont être 18 à tenter la sortie
tenter le tout pour le tout et à la
faveur de la nuit à la faveur du
brouillard vont réussir à sortir et à se
retrouver en bas dans la vallée toujours
ces mêmes 18 personnes et pour les
habitants de chichilian le pas de
l'aiguille à une signification toute
particulière le palais de l'Église c'est
un lieu historique mais que les gens
connaissent les anciens aujourd'hui ont
entendu les combats qui sont déroulés
ici ont accueilli les résistants et les
orientés c'est l'histoire vivante chez
nous et les employés municipaux c'est
leur père qui a fabriqué ce site donc
pour nous c'est pas une histoire des
livres c'est pas une histoire de concept
c'est c'est une histoire personnelle des
gens et quand on fait des cérémonies ici
les évocations sont presque des
invocations parce que du coup on voit
d'où sont arrivés les Allemands on voit
où se sont cachés dans tous les cas il y
a un esprit qui perdure dans ce lieu à
travers les gens à travers les
solidarités et à travers
l'investissement
c'est entretenu par des volontaires ou
par les employés communaux les gens font
ça avec cœur pour bien saisir les
combats dans le massif du Vercors il
faut aller visiter les deux autres sites
emblématiques de la mémoire nationale
Saint-Nizier-du-Moucherotte et Vassieux
en Vercors au total 600 maquisards et
200 civils et ont perdu la vie durant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
par la richesse du patrimoine dont il
est responsable le ministère des armées
est un acteur incontournable du tourisme
de mémoire 12 millions de visiteurs se
sont rendus l'année dernière sur les
lieux emblématiques du patrimoine
militaire un intérêt croissant lié au
dernier grandes commémorations des deux
conflits mondiaux mais aussi au travail
continu mené par le ministère et ses
partenaires en matière de tourisme de
mémoire
[Musique]